hello reject ville of the schmoeville
and screen junkies fans I am a magnesite
welcome to the real rejects Greg with me
is a lovely ania star anita star is a
youtube we say this very loosely yes
thank you to earn you now's as well the
Jairo Magnus introduced us it did
Tyrone's up now I need ain't exactly
what you'd call like a movie buff person
no I'm not but I'm eating have you heard
of Drew Barrymore oh my god have I ever
Greg well drew Barrymore than the new
Netflix movie or show I'm not sure which
it is called santa clarita diet
I love trailers because I'm a movies and
that's my passion in my heart rate
versatile up
I just love compassion I love talking
movies and I was like alright you know
we usually forget you should just do
like YouTube videos but I figured you're
in the horror and maybe this is meant
for [ __ ] on more bang for [ __ ] but
not anymore Greg not anymore and Rishi
has an e know I have this magic gift
shall we towards me late at night she
and Ben are selling their home it's a
beautiful property
great location you kitchen I think
they'll give up the listing that'd be
great honey
we can't be realtor's if we don't have
listings I already want to watch in
seven
huh what life was amazing trailers but
something happened to my wife I can't be
my heartbeat what she flew up there she
I didn't have formaldehyde so I faked
inaudible that was a crazy amount of
vomit
well Melia black Fergie was a huge Allah
she's acting different I can cook that
for you sweetheart
his mom died she is dead and also on
some and whatnot work
I think it's inherently negative I don't
want to be pearl it's not using I do
like the way that I see all right and I
really see and I sleep two hours a night
pick it up so much time you eat people I
know it's just I'm a much more confident
undead or completely driven by their it
but if I can't control myself and I risk
everything that matters to me what are
you up to this hello we are not gonna
fail on you know wha
we have to just order dessert
the product I could be a young single
Hitler god we'd be heroes
ya know we [ __ ] everything up together
[Music]
a realtor
are you residential but commercial and
request I guess that I'm yeah haven't
been my I'm actually genuinely excited
for this new show no it's not us I
excited I think the reason why is
because there's no prior content you
know I've been excited for shows like oh
when I hear like Marvel has a new show
coming to Netflix you know but I'm like
well there's already like previous
investment built into it in some
capacity this is a totally original conk
yeah I'm like I gotta watch this show
this looks tears well actually there was
live didn't they try a show on that
flicks called like iZombie or something
weird like that and it kind of had the
same concept ish but not as funny I
didn't watch it I saw like I think the
first CW show you I'm not sure I just
thought of Netflix I don't know network
Martin you know okay not meeting was on
Netflix and it was like I think it was
like a zombie or something along the
lines yeah but yeah I was it was like
she was a zombie and it was but it
wasn't it's funny and this I would
actually watch more than two episodes I
mean because it's on Netflix this looks
like it will deliver on ya jig or yeah
yeah and which I think enhances the
world a lot I think zombie comedies are
great I really like Sean Gadd zombie
well yeah there's other great ones Susan
not as popular for this I feel it would
be a great entry into that and another
thing I love too are like twisted love
story and this is such a twisted love
tale about this husband and wife like I
mean Timothy Olyphant is saying that in
the beginning that him and drew
Barrymore were already good I was kind
of taking about live like it maybe it
wasn't that great and this might bring
them even closer together or it might be
neat to just see a couple that already
love each other they're just so
inseparable they's like I'm gonna stick
with you through the end part and I like
kinda Manson it's very romantic it feels
romantic romantic fitting comedy yeah
like you can't get any better than that
seems like such a great show in a
painting place in Santa Clarita of all
places
it's where you people who don't live in
California Santa Clarita is a fairly
like up class like like where Magic
Mountain is like we're Magic Mountain is
us how high class is it's not know
that's were like rich white families
tend to go to and the occasional like Oh
rich Hispanic family what are they
really doing here
oh crap would I comment comment below
and tell us how racist we are for that
one little joke we make wait Timothy off
line drew Barrymore playing off each
other yes I know my chemistry yeah I'm
like in the chemistry this definitely is
going to be an entertaining show because
especially with that like surreal hiding
this love it all would like the way
Heather actor acting is like it doesn't
seem like it's exactly real yeah what
they believe what's going in like their
personalities are so heightened but it's
like they get the concept of the world
so well like it seems like this could be
like a magical kind of entertaining show
in its own way I think a family chain
you guys like cameos iPad and all bald
hair you got Nathan Fillion here's oh no
I can't
the one your great show I'm really
excited a lot you know I'm glad you made
me watch his trailer because I didn't
even know about the show I didn't know
it existed
and Drew Barrymore hasn't had anything
hot in a long time she's pretty hot I
mean she's still hot yeah yeah a lot I
mean there was an 80 she's been you know
harberger you know you liked her when
she was a little girl
preferred her needs well I would like a
little kid when I saw that Marcia water
oh yeah we're like 48 years old it was
2020 came I was 21 he watched me like
that yeah I think everything about this
show looks great I like to play on the
zombie world because he's not exactly a
you know a typical zombie right but she
isn't she's like I can't I don't know
I'd like to know like the rules of you
know her the unification yeah yeah
there's gonna be a great show can't wait
I'm excited to watch this
yeah I love Netflix when they do a show
because it's like they give you a bunch
of episode the one yeah and you're eager
like yeah you shut up unlike me where I
still haven't caught up with the walking
dead yet because Netflix well this is a
great companion piece they're exactly
the same
yeah she just called this you know
walking dead to Santa Clarita yeah
the walking Center water table leg
zombie let's color water okay bit rate
impression yeah like a drunk clown
yeah what was that he's ready what's
that Steven all right read yes if you're
needed a channel subscribe today and get
excited my catch phrase I would always
forget to say I needed star don't know
how to describe her videos they're funny
alright she does funny with you she's a
funny girl he's a beautiful girl thank
you so when you get funny and beautiful
in the same combination she ain't like
some typical white girl on YouTube no
ethical white girl and that's what I
love about her she came it was like
exotic you are you merited Nikhil you
know it's too far [ __ ] down they're
gonna go to my channel be like we were
expecting like this sexy exotic and you
got to like awkward girl next door that
you're too afraid to talk to because
weird their goodness awesome too much
you know well we're in a relationship
well yes because that happened because
we're both awkward exotic looking beings
yes ironic haha I'm gonna get so much
tigress with you hey you know like I can
be the community waited why not exactly
[ __ ] it work work I don't have some
we're gonna build this or watch my
channel and see Tyrone was into you now
we're dating
then we're going to talk about Tyrone
and sleeping with you while we're doing
all gonna just slow my job is easily
swallow
oh dude to death where is backwards and
through the roof how can I are you
getting a view my channel just going to
blow up